hey guys my name is just McDowell it is
a fourth of August today and you're
watching games what news destiny special
editions have become available for
pre-order but the ghost edition is sold
out at every retailer and that's where
the internet comes in the popular
edition included a replica ghost a
steelbook case and arms and armament
field guide postcards about destiny lore
and some in-game perks as well as access
to the game's expansion packs apparently
it's so in demand that copies of the
ghost edition are now selling on ebay
from between 300 bucks to an insane 1025
dollars although there's a chance that
one is an outlier you guys weren't so
keen for a remaster of Bioshock when it
seemed that that was on the horizon but
now it seems that 2 k's announcement
really referred to a mobile port of the
game how do you feel now the game is
coming to ipad and iphone from 2k china
the company haven't confirmed pricing
but have told gamers to expect a premium
priced mobile game which will be out
later this summer how senior editor
Justin hey world cracked into the game
and noted that the sound design and
graphics leaves something to be desired
although the port is very true to the
original game and likely to dole out the
warm nostalgic feels check out our story
on site for a more detailed preview of
bioshock's Newport tropico 5 has been
banned in Thailand apparently according
to the game potentially causing havoc to
peace and order Thailand's military
junta has said the game won't be sold
due to some part of its content being
inappropriate Thailand has been under a
military dictatorship since May when
soldiers overthrew the government
according to the Associated Press
Thailand also has fairly strong
censorship laws when it comes to other
forms of media where cigarettes and
alcohol a blurred out on TV and there's
been a crackdown on scenes which the
authorities deemed to be immoral
pornographic or critical which a dev CD
Projekt RED have laid the smackdown on
Microsoft today and here's what they had
to say CD Projekt RED have noted that
even though Microsoft introduced its
newest iteration
of Direct X this hasn't changed or
improved the ability to render games at
1080p on xbox one Microsoft promised
that the software would bring rich
Essenes more objects and full
utilization of modern GPU hardware for
future games on Microsoft platforms CD
Projekt RED say this isn't really the
case follow her lead engine programmer
for The Witcher explained most games out
there can't go 1080p because the
additional load on the shading units
would be too much for all these games
DirectX 12 is not going to change
anything they might be able to push more
triangles to the GPU but they are not
going to be able to shade them which
defeats the purpose ask your question of
the day let me know if you'd shell out
your hard-earned dollars for an
out-of-stock collector's edition and if
so for what game that is it for your
Monday dose of news I'll be back same
time tomorrow with a bunch more things
to say so I'll get to them